[Music]
hey everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of Fandango indie
movie Guide the show where I run you
through these little films that you
should definitely try to see in theaters
this week if you love to lobster and dog
tooth and you're a little bit of a
weirdo like me who loves dark and
disturbing films then you have to check
out the killing of a sacred deer this is
the latest film by director jurgis lan
thermos who was behind the two films I
just mentioned Colin Farrell stars in
this one as a doctor with Nicole Kidman
as his wife Colin Farrell's character
strikes up a friendship of sorts with a
young boy named Martin played
brilliantly by Barry Keough I won't see
one more thing I'm really sorry about
bought it's nothing serious
no it is they will all get sick and die
Bob will die Kim all day your wife will
die understand
no don't this is the kind of film that
will get under your skin and you can see
it in a very symbolic way or you can
just see it as a very terrifying family
drama the cinematography the production
design the performances and the score
which is haunting it all adds up to a
level of Terror which is sustained
throughout you will also laugh and
that's part of yoga says brilliance that
he could make you squirm one second and
chortle the next
[Music]
and it's all tolls with his very deadpan
style of dialogue the killing of a
sacred deer is not a film that you'll
forget very easily try and find it in
cinemas this weekend if you want to have
an experience three films out this
weekend that I want to run through very
very quickly the first in theaters
wonderstruck directed by Todd Haynes who
also did Carol this tells the story of
two kids who both struggle with their
hearing one in the 1920s one in the
1970s the production design is
cinematography are amazing I
particularly loved the 1920s portion
which is very much like a silent movie
wonderstruck stars Julianne Moore and
you can find it in theaters this weekend
this is a story about what makes us
different
[Music]
and about having the courage to find the
place where we belong how do you know
Wendy
also in theaters maybe a little bit hard
to find but worth seeking out is BPM
this was a favorite from the Cannes Film
Festival about a group of AIDS activists
but bigger than just focusing on the
disease it focuses on the very human
stories great characters and it will
suck you in emotionally try to find BPM
if you can in limited theaters this
weekend my best working policy - MS
she comes here she had resentencing on
issues
[Music]
and once the home if you want to stay in
and watch Fandango now then I highly
recommend Steph it's the documentary
about a group of girls who are involved
in a step dance troupe in Baltimore they
each come from tough backgrounds which
make them struggle to get through school
but it's an inspirational story and one
that we women need right about now
check out Steph available on Fandango
now this weekend that's why me if you
come together with a little powerful
view the impact will be immense stop his
life so to give you my picks once again
in theaters check out the killing of a
sacred deer wonderstruck or BPM and at
home on Fandango now you can see step a
great documentary
I'm Alicia Malone and my question of the
week for you is do you like films that
make you feel uncomfortable or are you
one to go to the cinema just to have a
good time let me know in the comments
below or you can tweet me at Alicia
Malone and I'll see you next week bye
[Music]